CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT, NOT
PROSECUTION.
LAURA?
>> Laura: CURIOUS.
CHRIST, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
JOINING ME NOW EXCLUSIVELY IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PERSONAL
ATTORNEY, RUDY GIULIANI.
ALL RIGHT, MR. MAYOR, RUBIO SAYS
TAKE A CHILL PILL, BASICALLY,
THIS SUBPOENA FOR DON JR.,
APPARENTLY JUST PART OF GENERAL,
GENERIC OVERSIGHT.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TONIGHT?
>> I RESPECT BOTH SENATORS VERY,
VERY MUCH.
I'VE ACTUALLY CAMPAIGN FOR BOTH
OF THEM.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
OVERSIGHT IS.
HE TESTIFIED FOR 29 HOURS, I
THINK.
SO MAYBE THERE IS A QUESTION OR
TWO AGO THAT WASN'T, THEY CAN
SEND HIM AN INTERROGATORY AND
GET AN ANSWER.
I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU WOULD
HARASS THE MAN MORE THAN YOU
HAVE.
MUELLER CAME TO A VERY
DEFINITIVE CONCLUSION THAT
DONALD TRUMP JR. DID NOTHING
WRONG.
THAT THERE WAS NO SUGGESTION HE
WOULD HAVE ANY REASON TO HAVE
BELIEVED IT WAS A VIOLATION OF
THE LAW TO MEET WITH THAT
RUSSIAN WOMAN.
IT TURNS OUT INTERESTING PART OF
THAT MEETING IS IT LOOKS LIKE A
SET UP BY A FUSION, BECAUSE THE
WOMAN MET WITH GLENN SIMPSON, TE
HEAD OF THE OUTCOME OF THE
DAY BEFORE, THE DAY OF, THE DAY
AFTER.
THEY NEVER FOLLOWED UP.
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS A LONG
TIME, IF THAT ISN'T A SET UP, I
WOULD BE REALLY SURPRISED.
I'D RATHER SEE THEM LOOK INTO
THAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY COULD
POSSIBLY ASK DONALD TRUMP JR.
THAT WASN'T ASKED --
>> Laura: I THINK THEY ARE
GOING, IT SOUNDS LIKE THE FOCUS
IN PART WOULD BE ON THE
DISCUSSION TO BUILD TRUMP TOWER
IN MOSCOW BEFORE THE ELECTION
ACTUALLY TOOK PLACE.
>> WHAT DOES THAT HAVE TO DO
WITH OVERSIGHT?
THAT SOUNDS LIKE AN
INVESTIGATION AGAIN.
>> Laura: I'VE GOT SO MANY
TEXT TODAY FROM FRIENDS WHO
AREN'T REALLY ALL THAT
POLITICAL, BUT THEY WERE JUST,
WHAT?
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO US.
I DIDN'T HAVE A GOOD ANSWER FOR
ANY OF THEM.
ALL RIGHT, RUDY, I HAVE TO BRING
THIS UP BECAUSE I THOUGHT OF YOU
WHEN I HEARD THAT CNN WAS DOING
A TOWN HALL TONIGHT, NOT WITH A
2020 CANDIDATE, BUT WITH YOUR
FAVORITE FORMER FBI DIRECTOR,
JIM COMEY, BECAUSE HE WAS OUT OF
THE REDWOOD TREES, AND HE WAS
MARKING HIS TWO-YEAR ANNIVERSARY
OF BEING FIRED BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
LISTEN, BECAUSE HE IS STILL NOT
OVER IT.
>> DO YOU THINK YOU SHOULD BE
CHARGED WHEN HE IS OUT OF OFFIC
OFFICE?
>> I THINK THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WILL HAVE TO TAKE A
SERIOUS LOOK AT THAT, WHETHER IT
IS A WISE THING TO DO TO A
FORMER PRESIDENT, I DON'T KNOW.
>> YOU THINK THE EVIDENCE IS
THERE TO PROSECUTE?
>> IT SURE LOOKS LIKE IT IS
THERE WITH RESPECT TO AT LEAST A
COUPLE OF THOSE EPISODES OF
OBSTRUCTION.
>> Laura: RUDY, COMEY
PERSISTS.
>> I APOLOGIZE FOR HAVING HIRED
HIM YEARS AGO AS AN ASSISTANT
U.S. ATTORNEY.
I'M VERY EMBARRASSED ABOUT THAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO
JIM COMEY.
TODAY'S REVELATION BY JOHN
SOLOMON IS A BLOCKBUSTER.
IT WAS CLEAR TO THE
STATE DEPARTMENT THAT THE STEELE
DOSSIER WAS A COMPLETE PHONY.
THIS MEMO WAS CIRCULATED.
IF HE DIDN'T READ IT, HE WAS
SLEEPING.
I HAVE READ PART OF THAT
DOSSIER, AND I HAVE DONE THIS
FISA STUFF FOR YEARS, I WAS
THERE WHEN IT FIRST STARTED.
IF YOU CAN FIGURE OUT THAT THE
STEELE DOSSIER IS A PIECE OF
JUNK, AND YOU SHOULDN'T BE FBI
DIRECTOR.
I HAVE NO DOUBT, HE'S GOT A
SERIOUS PROBLEM HAVING PUT HIS
NAME ON THAT AFFIDAVIT AND NOT
REVEALED THAT IT WAS UNVERIFIED,
NOT REVEALED THAT HE TOOK NO
STEPS TO VERIFY IT.
WHEN A STATE DEPARTMENT EMPLOYEE
WAS ABLE TO FIGURE OUT THAT
STEELE LIED ABOUT THERE BEING A
CONSULATE IN MIAMI FOR THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT.
THAT STEELE LIED -- HE HADN'T
BEEN IN MOSCOW, HADN'T BEEN IN
RUSSIA FOR NINE YEARS.
>> Laura: WHY DO THEY KEEP
USING HIM?
WHY DID THE FBI CONTINUE TO RELY
ON CHRISTOPHER STEELE, EVEN
AFTER HE BROKE THE DEAL IN LATE
SUMMER, I BELIEVE AUGUST OF
2016?
HE BROKE THE DEAL, WAS DEEMED
UNRELIABLE, BUT THEN IT LOOKS
LIKE THEY STILL KEPT USING THE
FRUITS OF HIS LABOR WITH HIS
DOSSIER.
AND HIM.
>> ALL DURING THAT PERIOD, COMEY
NEVER ATTEMPTED TO VERIFY IT.
HE HAD FIVE MONTHS TO DO IT.
WHEN HE WENT TO THE PRESIDENT IN
EARLY JANUARY OF 2017 AND SAID
IT IS UNVERIFIED AND SALACIOUS,
HE HAD FIVE MONTHS TO VERIFY IT.
IF HE HAD VERIFIED IT, HE
WOULD'VE FOUND OUT VERY
EASILY --
>> Laura: HE DIDN'T WANT TO
VERIFY --
>> FIVE AREAS THAT WERE
ABSOLUTELY UNTRUE.
HE NEVER REVEALED TO THE COURT
THAT THIS WAS A PAID FOR
POLITICAL DOCUMENT BY
HILLARY CLINTON.
THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS.
>> Laura: I WANT TO MOVE ON TO
THE BACKLASH YOU HAVE BEEN
RECEIVING FOR CALLING ON THE
DOJ, I GUESS TO INVESTIGATE
BIDEN AND HIS FAMILY.
YOU HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT THIS
BEFORE ON THE SHOW.
HIS QUESTIONABLE TIES TO THE
UKRAINE, ESPECIALLY THE
SWEETHEART PAYDAY, HUNTER BIDEN
ENDED UP GETTING.
HERE ARE JUST A FEW OF THE
EXAMPLES.
LET'S LISTEN PEERS >> GIULIANI,
THE PRESIDENT'S PERSONAL
ATTORNEY, HAS BEEN PUSHING THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO GO HARD ON
HUNTER BIDEN'S
TIES TO UKRAINE.
>> IT IS A BLATANT USE TO USE
FOREIGN POWER TO TARNISH TRUMP'S
ELECTION OPPONENT THAT >> LOU
RUDY GIULIANI IS TELEGRAPHING
IT.
THEY ALMOST WANT TO CREATE
FOREIGN INTERFERENCE, THROW IN
UKRAINE, RUSSIANS, GIULIANI HAS
BEEN TO THE UKRAINE HAS
UKRAINIAN CLIENTS.
>> THEY ARE OUT OF THEIR MINDS.
>> Laura: HOLD ON, JUST IN THE
LAST HOUR, IT GETS BETTER.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" POSTED ON
ONLINE "GIULIANI HAD THE TRIP TO
PUSH FOR INQUIRIES THAT COULD
HELP TRUMP," LIKE YOU ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO TRAVEL, APPARENTLY.
>> I AM HIS LAWYER.
LAWYERS, WHEN THEY DEFEND A
CLIENT, DEVELOP HYPOTHESIS,
EXPLANATION OF WHAT YOUR CLIENT
WAS CHARGED WITH.
THE FACT IS THIS WAS A MASSIVE
COLLUSION BETWEEN THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL COMMITTEE, OFFICIALS OF
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION,
CLINTON PEOPLE, AND THE
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS, CORRUPT
OFFICIALS -- WHO BY THE WAY WERE
PRO-RUSSIAN CORRUPT OFFICIALS.
TO CREATE FALSE INFORMATION
ABOUT TRUMP, ABOUT MANAFORT.
THIS IS REAL -- NOT COLLUSION,
CONSPIRACY TO PRESENT FALSE
INFORMATION, AND TO LEAK IT TO
THE PRESS, AND TO GIVE IT TO THE
FBI.
THE UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT IS
PRESENTLY INVESTIGATING IT.
MY AIM IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
TESORO'S REPRESENTATIVES, WHO
HAVE A LOT OF INFLUENCE IN THAT
GOVERNMENT, AND A VERY HIGHLY
CORRUPT UKRAINIAN WHO ACTUALLY
PARTICIPATED IN CREATING A FALSE
DOCUMENT ABOUT PAUL MANAFORT,
ACTUALLY, HE HAS BEEN FOUND
GUILTY OF BAD BY THE UKRAINIAN
COURT.
TO BE WHEN I SAW THAT.
>> THAT THEY DO NOT PREVENT THE
CONTINUATION OF THIS
INVESTIGATION.
ALL THEY WANT UKRAINIAN
GOVERNMENT TO DO IS INVESTIGATE,
AND DON'T LET THESE PEOPLE
BUFFALO YOU.
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO
DO.
BIDEN CAME TO ME --
>> Laura: WHY ISN'T THE MEDIA
PURSUING THIS?
>> THE MEDIA IS TOTALLY CORRUPT!
>> Laura: IT'S A FASCINATING
STORY, AND EVERYONE --
>> IT IS A BIG STORY.
IT IS A DRAMATIC STORY.
I GUARANTEE YOU, JOE BIDEN WILL
NOT GET TO ELECTION DAY WITHOUT
THIS BEING INVESTIGATED.
NOT BECAUSE I WANT TO SEE HIM
INVESTIGATED.
THIS IS COLLATERAL TO WHAT I WAS
DOING.
BUT HERE ARE THE FACTS, LAURA.
JOE BIDEN WAS APPOINTED THE
POINT MAN FOR UKRAINE.
TWO TO THREE WEEKS LATER, HIS
SON, HUNTER, WHO I JUST BEEN
TOSSED OUT OF THE MILITARY FOR
TESTING POSITIVE FOR COCAINE,
WAS APPOINTED TO A POSITION ON
THE MOST CORRUPT AGENCY, THE
MOST CORRUPT BUSINESS IN UKRAIN
UKRAINE.
A NATURAL GAS BUSINESS CALLED
BURISMA, WHICH WAS HEADED BY AN
OLIGARCH WHO WAS BEING PROTECTED
BY PUTIN IN RUSSIA.
AND BIDEN'S KID TOOK DOWN ABOUT
$3 MILLION OR $4 MILLION THAT WE
COULD COUNT.
AND WHEN THE KID GOT UNDER
INVESTIGATION, ACTUALLY SAYS "I
STRONG-ARMED THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UKRAINE TO DISMISS THE
PROSECUTOR BECAUSE THE SON OF --
I WILL LEAVE IT OUT -- WAS
CORRUPT."
WHAT HE LEFT OUT OF THE
EXPLANATION WAS THE PROSECUTOR
WAS RIGHT ON THE TAIL OF HIS
SON, LOOKING FOR THE MONEY THAT
APPEARED TO HAVE BEEN LAUNDERED
FROM LATVIA TO CROATIA TO
AMERICA.
AND WHEN HE TRIED TO GET THE
CROATIAN GOVERNMENT TO GIVE THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT HUNTER
BIDEN RECEIVED, ALL OF A SUDDEN
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UKRAINE
GETS A CALL FROM THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, AND HE HAS TOLD
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO GET YOUR
$1.2 BILLION LOAN GUARANTEE,
WHICH THEY NEEDED THEN TO
PREVENT DEFAULT, UNLESS YOU
DISMISS THE PROSECUTOR.
THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T WANT TO DO
IT, BUT HE WAS THE GODFATHER OF
THE PROSECUTOR'S CHILDREN.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO DO IT.
>> Laura: THIS IS LIKE A JAMES
PATTERSON NOVEL.
>> INVESTIGATED BETWEEN NOW AND
ELECTION DAY, THEN OUR JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT --
>> Laura: EXPERIENCE AND
NATURAL GAS --
>> DONALD TRUMP AND
DONALD TRUMP JR., THIS IS GOING
TO BE THE FRONT PAGE OF EVERY
ONE OF THOSE NEWSPAPERS --
>> Laura: CHUCK TODD WILL BE
ROLLING HIS EYES.
SPEAK OF BEST EVIDENCE I HAVE
SEEN OF MEDIA CORRUPTION.
>> Laura: RUDY, I WANT TO GET
BACK TO COMEY, BECAUSE MORE IS
COMING IN ON WHAT HE SAID
TONIGHT.
THIS KIND OF GOES IN LINE WITH
THE LETTER FROM OVER 800 FORMER
PROSECUTORS WHO SAID THAT THEY
THINK THE CONDUCT OF TRUMP
DESCRIBED IN THE MUELLER REPORT
DOES AMOUNT TO OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
BUT HE SPECIFICALLY WAS ASKED IF
HE BELIEVES THE PRESIDENT
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> DO YOU THINK HE HAD CRIMINAL
INTENT, BASED ON WHAT YOU HAVE
SEEN IN THE MUELLER REPORT?
>> IT SURE LOOKS LIKE HE DID, IN
CONNECTION WITH A COUPLE OF
EPISODES BEAR THE DIRECTION TO
DON McGAHN TO GET THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL FIRED, TO MY MIND, IS A
FLAMING EXAMPLE.
YES, OF CORRUPT INTENT.
>> THIS IS THE GUY, LAURA, WHO
COULDN'T MAKE A CORRUPTION CASE
WHEN 33,000 EMAILS WERE DELETED.
CELL PHONES WERE DESTROYED WITH
HAMMERS, AND SERVERS WERE
BLEACHED.
AND HE COULDN'T MAKE A
CORRUPTION CASE BASED ON THAT.
THAT IS CORRUPTION, WHEN YOU
DESTROY EVIDENCE.
THIS IS A CASE IN WHICH THE
PRESIDENT WAS INNOCENT OF THE
UNDERLYING CHARGES, AND HE WAS
DEFENDING HIMSELF AGAINST
MALICIOUS, LOOKS TO ME LIKE VERY
WELL ORGANIZED, CORRUPT CHARGES
AGAINST HIMSELF.
NO PROSECUTOR IN THE WORLD WOULD
BRING THIS CASE.
AND THE PEOPLE THAT GOT TO SIGN
THAT, I GUARANTEE YOU, THERE IS
NOT A SINGLE ONE THAT VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
AND I HAVE NEVER HEARD OF
PROSECUTORS OPINING ON A CASE
THEY DON'T KNOW ABOUT.
THAT IS A POLITICAL STATEMENT.
THAT IS NOT A PROSECUTORIAL
MEMO.
THEY SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
THEMSELVES.
THEY DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
THIS CASE.
ALL THEY KNOW IS WHAT THEY READ
IN THE NEWSPAPERS ON WHAT THEY
GET FROM THE HIGHLY BIASED
REPORT, 440 PAGE DIATRIBE, THAT
IS A COMPLETE VIOLATION OF
PROSECUTORIAL EFFORTS.
>> Laura: WHAT I THINK IT
TELLS ME, ONCE AGAIN, WHY I
DON'T TRUST A LOT OF PROSECUTORS
TODAY.
SORRY.
>> A LOT OF GOOD FRIENDS --
>> Laura: SOME OF THESE PEOPLE
ARE OUT OF CONTROL --
>> ASHAMED OF THEM, BECAUSE YOU
DID NOT OFFER AN OPINION BASED
ON A CASE YOU DIDN'T
INVESTIGATE.
IF YOU DO, YOU ARE DOING A
POLITICAL STATEMENT, NOT A LEGAL
MEMO LEGAL MEMO.
>> Laura: POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR, IT'S A SCANDAL.
MR. MAYOR, I KNOW YOU COULD HAVE
GONE ON THE ON A LOT OF SHOWS.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOU COMING
ON COMING ON.
>> I GUARANTEE YOU, THIS WILL
EVENTUALLY BE INVESTIGATED, AND
IT WILL BE A MASSIVE SCANDAL.
YOU CAN'T ESCAPE THE FACT.
I'VE SEEN THEM.
I'VE SEEN THE CORROBORATION.
I'VE SEEN TAPES.
THIS IS A VERY BIG CASE, AND A
MISUSE OF OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT